have you ever been to Disney World okay
how much money you probably spend when
you go to dinner
at least a thousand at least a thousand
give me all the kids yeah at the hotel
oh you're talking hotel and everything
every weekend yes four or five thousand
dollars at least four or five thousand
dollars yeah how much money will you
spend on your Netflix subscription over
your whole life oh great question that's
a good question probably less than that
thousand maybe yeah and you got six
different people using the same one like
so there's no way Netflix is going to be
able to compete long term with a brand
like Disney unless they start doing
these like live experience and things
and they have tried they're doing like
stranger things live right you got to
get people outside there has to be other
streams of Revenue like Disney's in
everything so even if they're not making
money off the movies they got money
coming in from Disney World Paris and
they got the merch lines it's like it's
so hard to compete with them